si vous prenez une petite pause pendant
votre travail vous voulez pas que votre
bosse le sache voici comment faire sur
votre iPhone vous voulez activer votre
mode Concentration allez faire du yoga
mais faut le dire à personne et bien
c'est facile vous venez dans vos
réglages vous allez dans concentration
et vous descendez sur statut
concentration vous partagez le statut ne
pas déranger repos travail mais vous ne
partagez pas le statut yoga vous n'aurez
pas volotifications vous ne serez pas
dérangé mais votre boss ne sera pas que
vous êtes en train de faire du yoga
pendant vos heures de travail c'est
plutôt malin non